So, at a certain level,
if you have this kind of CEO mentality
and I tell everyone I work with,
don't wait for,
you have license to lead.
Dan Rubinstein,
thank you for being on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm doing great.
Thank you for having me here.
Of course, I have to say that
I love the brightness of your space.
It's very important for me
to also be in a bright space as I work.
And it looks like you have a great setup.
And I have to, before we dive into
all the incredible
stuff that you've done,
whether it's running a company
that had over 120 patents,
or being an executive at various
of the most well-known companies,
you're a songwriter.
Tell me about that.
Yes.
It's something I fell into, actually.
When my son was five years old
he got interested
in taking violin lessons.
The reason he got interested
in violin lessons is actually also
a funny story.
We took him to a symphony concert
and he saw that violinist
was the one that was setting the
tuning for the entire orchestra.
Right.
The first violinist.
And so he said,
"Oh, I want to study the violin."
I love that. He wants to lead.
So, we signed him up for violin lessons.
And normally it was during the workday.
So, my wife would take him
in the afternoon.
And one day she couldn't make it.
She was also working at the time.
And so I said,
"Sure, I'd be happy to take him."
And I went there with him
and I was so excited
to do something like that with him.
I came home and I told my wife,
"I'm going to study violin
together with him."
She looks at me, she goes,
"You're crazy.
You play the guitar already.
Why don't you do more with guitar?"
And so, I ended up looking for
how can I expand my horizons with guitar.
I ended up studying jazz guitar.
And then, as I was learning
all these chords and melodies,
I started setting poetry to the music.
And over time I just started
writing more and more songs.
And it's been fun.
I've actually, I'm about to publish
an album in a few weeks.
My first album,
it's called, Stolen Moments.
Stolen Moments.
I have to say I'm surprised
that I'm not surprised.
It keeps amazing me
how the busiest people
that I get to interview
are the ones that are doing
the most amazing things
and the ones that are
following their passions.
And I just love it.
I have to say that I'm also drawing
a very big pile to my own father.
He's a fantastic mathematician.
He's also in the high tech industry
for a long time.
But he's a jazz musician.
And he plays
with his friends
all the time.
And you make time for your passions.
I just love it.
But Dan, you know,
Princeton Masters
and Masters at Stanford,
PhD in Statistics in Stanford.
You go on to be the president
and the CEO of Reflectivity.
Right?
It's sold to Texas Instruments
with over 120 patents.
And so, your whole journey,
then moving on to Google
and Facebook and Palantir,
talk to me a little bit about,
did you plan ahead to do so many
incredible things on your journey?
Was there any strategy
in planning this ahead?
You know, I'll tell you,
it's a funny story.
Because I don't think you can predict
10, 20, 30 years out.
Everyone thinks they know
what they're going to be doing,
but it's very hard to know
where the world is going to go.
So, when I was growing up,
both my parents were engineers.
And I got very interested in engineering.
And at the end of high school, I started
we had an apple to clone, but my dad had
built from a kit and sold it himself.
And I started getting interested
in programming it.
And one of the first programs,
serious programs that I built
was actually a program
to conjugate Hebrew verbs.
Wow.
So, yeah.
It was a very nice program.
I created shape tables
for all the Hebrew alphabet.
And you know, the Hebrew grammar
is very mathematical and orderly,
so you can actually create
a very clear algorithm
for how to conjugate different words
based on their letters.
And when I was applying to universities,
the guy who interviewed me for Princeton
was actually an engineer and a linguist,
and he got very interested
in what I was doing.
And he said,
"Look, if you get into Princeton,
send me a letter.
And if you know how to code,
I can hire you."
He was working
at Bell Northern Research in Montreal
doing speech recognition.
And so from there,
I got very interested in,
this is automated speech recognition.
Today, everyone takes it for granted
that you can pick up your phone
and talk to Siri.
But back then,
this was new groundbreaking stuff.
And I got very interested
and very passionate in
how do you train computers to recognize
human speech, human handwriting,
all these kinds of questions.
And that's what led me to go to Stanford
and get my PhD in that field.
Driven by curiosity.
That's what I'm hearing here.
Very, very cool.
Before you continue,
because it has to go
side by side with this,
this curiosity also leads you to then
create a company
that is steered by curiosity,
where you don't just stumble upon
creating a 120 patents
selling to Texas Instruments?
So, that's actually funny,
because when I was at Stanford
finishing my PhD in statistics,
the thing that I thought
I was going to do,
and this is back in 1998,
which is constantly the same time
that Google was getting started,
I thought I was going to go
and start a data mining company.
I was taking
entrepreneurship classes at Stanford,
learning,
including at the business school,
thinking about,
okay, I want to start a company.
I'm very interested in data.
Internet was I mean,
the websites were coming up
on the Internet.
So, this is all very new
and very exciting.
And so, that's where I was headed.
And then my roommate,
my grad school roommate,
came up with a way of
making a micromirror display.
So, this is a tiny display on a chip.
I actually have one here
on my desk to share with you.
I don't know if you can see it.
Yes.
That silver thing in the middle there
is actually a 1024 x 768
high resolution display.
So, on this little chip,
there is almost a million little mirrors
that move
their electrostatic they're actuated.
Each pixel corresponds
to one of these mirrors.
You apply a voltage and electrode
under the mirror and the mirrors is
electrostatic attracted and bends.
And so, you can control
where the light goes.
You shine a bright light on it,
if the mirror is flat
the light bounces from that pixel
and you don't see it.
And if you apply voltage,
the pixel bends
and the light reaches the projector
and then reduce it.
And you get color
by spinning red, green, blue light.
And so, we started a company
called, Reflectivity
to develop these micro displays
for business projectors
and large screen TVs.
The classic dorm story.
Yeah. If anyone knew
what they were doing,
they would never start this company
because it was the most difficult,
technically challenging thing.
So, the patents, it's not like
we had 120 patents
that we knew going into it that,
oh, we're going to invent
all this thing. No.
Dan, you needed so much new technology
to make it work.
Yeah. We had a 120 problems
that resulted in 120 patents.
So, we had so many innovative things
that we did there.
We built our own H-System.
We actually were talking to companies
like Applied Materials
to license our H-System.
So, building this chip required so much
surrounding technology that it just,
you know, necessity,
is the mother of invention.
If you have a problem
you have to invent a solution.
That's where it came from.
I'm already upset that we only have
20 minutes for this interview.
And that's why I have to move forward.
Because you go from there,
you sell to Texas Instruments,
you become a product management director
at Google then Facebook,
and then you find yourself
as an entrepreneur in residence
at Khosla Ventures, one of the most
well known venture capital firms
in Silicon Valley,
primarily focused on health care, right?
I believe that's Khoslas.
And he came to speak to one of my classes
and he was talking about
the future of technology
with health care,
and it was mind blowing.
What was that about?
Why become an entrepreneur in residence
after being an executive
in three companies?
So, what happened was
while I was at Facebook,
my dad started getting,
complaining of lower back pain
and we thought he had sciatica.
He thought he had sciatica.
And this went on for months.
And it turned out he actually had
stage 4 lung cancer
that had metastasized to his bones.
And it didn't get diagnosed
for a long time properly.
And by the way, this is a PSA,
if you have any relatives over 65
that don't have a reason
for their lower back pain,
they didn't have a chronic back pain
for many years,
so they didn't have an acute trigger,
one of the things you should go look for
is could it be cancer.
Anyway, he wasn't a smoker,
so there's no indication that he had,
and he had no symptoms
of lung cancer per se.
And this kind of set me an idea,
why is it,
and this is 2012,
why are we in 2012
and something so basic
doesn't get diagnosed in time.
Just the idea that companies like Amazon,
and Google and Facebook,
you know, you go to Amazon,
they know what you want to buy
before you do, right?
You go to Google, you type a few letters
and Google tells you the whole sentence
of what you're searching for.
Why aren't they focusing
on also diagnosing cancer.
Yeah.
Or, why isn't health care
better use technology and data
the way these companies do.
And at least in the US,
there's several reasons for this.
I think the major one is that
we have this
approach to data privacy
that causes siloed data.
Right.
Companies like Amazon
and Google and Facebook,
they aggregate the data across all users
and builds very sophisticated
predictive models from that.
Health care, for the most part,
especially in the US,
doesn't work that way, right?
Data is protected. It's siloed.
And the efforts,
I don't think there's enough
being done to really leverage
the data and technology.
Right.
So, I got interested in health care
and seeing if we can bring this approach,
this philosophical approach
from the high tech world
to the health care world.
And I didn't know anything,
other than being a patient
from time to time, you know,
I didn't really know much
about health care.
So, I thought I would spend
a couple of years just trying
to immerse myself,
see where I could learn,
where I could help.
And so, the first opportunity
actually was,
I had known Vinod for many years,
because when we were fundraising
for Reflectivity,
we actually pitched him.
Really?
I think he was still at Kleiner Perkins
at the time, if I'm not mistaken.
Again Dan, I'm sorry to interrupt,
but I have to just draw a parallel.
Because when I ask you,
we're in April of 2014,
after you've had such
a fantastic career already that
the vast majority of people in high tech
can only dream of, right?
Selling your own company
that is doing deep technology,
then being a product management director
of two of some of the most
well sought out companies.
And then you're saying
that you wanted to spend a few year
s to immerse yourself in new technologies
and feed that inner curiosity.
And that's I think
that's the most inspirational
that I'm gaining from this whole journey.
It's this driven by curiosity
to the Stanford PhD to solving a problem
that turns into 120 problems,
to then immersing yourself in health care
because of a personal story.
I'm sorry, I just had to
put that in there.
Please continue.
Yeah.
So, what I really liked about Vinod,
he has a very strong vision perspective
around how health care should be done.
And it aligned very much
with the way I was thinking, you know.
Essentially, how can we superpower
clinicians and doctors using technology
in new and innovative ways.
And so, I was lucky.
He was very kind.
And I was able to get a position
as an entrepreneur and residence there.
And it really allowed me
to see new companies, help out
in due diligence.
And I was planning to spend
quite a while there.
And while I was there,
Palantir reached out
and recruited me to come in
for a senior product role
at their company.
And they had a health care practice
as well, which was aligned
with what I was interested in.
So, I thought, sure, let's go do this.
And then ultimately, after about a year,
I kind of decided if I was going to do,
the kind of vision I had
for my health care startup
was not going to be easily done there.
So, I set out on my own,
and joined forces with my colleague
Cameron Marlow, who was the former
head of data science at Facebook.
And we started Physera together.
First of all, it's a fantastic colleague
to bring on board.
Physera, it's the company
that you're currently running.
Tell me a little bit about it.
And what I particularly like
to also hear from you is
what is it like being
a second time entrepreneur
with your own company
that you're founding?
How is the process different
from the get go,
not just in terms of the experience
and the knowledge that you already have,
but also in terms of the perception
and getting people to buy into
what you're doing, which is often
one of the most difficult things
for a first time entrepreneur?
Yeah.
Look, I think
obviously any time you do
something twice,
you get better at it the second time.
I think,
one of the mistakes
a lot of entrepreneurs make,
and I certainly made this myself
the first time around,
you waste a lot of time on things
that don't actually matter, right?
So, and what I'm going to say
is going to sound obvious.
But when you do a company,
there's going to probably
one, two or small number of things
that you need to do exceptionally well,
that are different, that are new,
that no one else is doing.
And that's where you should be.
95% of your time
should be focused on that.
And then there's all these other things
that you need to do, like
the corporation who gets what shares,
hiring employees, the accounting,
the lease, the real estate.
And an entrepreneur, unfortunately,
especially when you're starting out,
you don't have money,
so you can't hire all these people.
So, you end up doing
a lot of that yourself.
But the quicker
you can get out of that game, the faster.
Now, the good news is
if I just look at the changes
that happened in the world between,
when I started my first company in 1998
and the second company in 2015,
it's not that much time.
But the world has changed dramatically,
and all the things,
now, you have WeWork,
you don't need to go and figure out
long term office.
Just go and get a desk at WeWork
and you can get started right away.
There's software
to start up your own company.
You don't need to hire accountants.
There's all these things that you can do.
So, if anything,
I think starting a company these days
has become much, much easier.
And you get to leverage
from all these services
and cloud computing
that you didn't have before.
100%. 100%.
So, I have to ask, you know,
we just have a couple of minutes left.
Dan, you do so many things.
You had so many experiences.
What was the most fun you've had?
Like, what do you enjoy being the CEO,
do you enjoy being the PM,
the entrepreneur in residence?
Which part of the puzzle?
Look.
I think every job I've had,
I think there's been something
amazing and fun on it.
And in some ways
they're very similar,
in some ways they're different.
So, when I went from being a CEO
of my own company to going to Google,
one of the things I realized very quickly
is actually,
a certain level of obstruction.
It's all the same.
When you're a CEO of a company,
you have employees,
you have to convince your board,
you have competitors.
You go to a company like Google,
the entities, they have different labels
and different names, but it's actually,
the same kinds of things.
Instead of having to convince investors,
you have to convince management
to fund a certain project.
You want to get an engineer on your team,
it's just it's almost the same
as recruiting an engineer
to come join your company.
So, at a certain level,
if you have this kind of CEO mentality,
and I tell everyone I work with,
don't wait for
you have license to lead.
License to lead. I like that.
Whatever you do in your company,
whether you're marketing or sales,
whatever function you have,
you have license to lead.
Bring the CEO mindset to your work.
So, you're not just doing a narrow thing.
Think about how it impacts
the broader problem.
And I think, you get
a lot of satisfaction
when you feel like I have ownership
of not just what I'm doing,
but everything.
It just becomes very satisfying.
So, when you ask me
what's been the most fun?
It's all been fun.
Because I bring the same mindset
to everything I do.
I love it.
I just love it.
Before we end this,
I have to thank you
for being a source of inspiration
for myself and many others
within J-Ventures,
the early stage fund
we're both involved with.
Whether it's the screening meetings
that I just love hearing
both you and [--]
and everybody else's,
but also in the monthly meetings.
Tell me a little bit about,
about your experience with J-Ventures
and investing in general,
because you're wearing both hats, right?
You're both taking three hats.
Tech executive,
entrepreneur and investor.
Is it just a big mishmash?
Or are you really differentiating
into different buckets of your life?
Again, I think it's all aligned
in the same pursuit of trying to, I mean,
you know the concept of Tikkun Olam,
which to repair the world,
to make the world better.
So, in my personal life,
this is what I enjoy.
This is how I want to spend my time
making and finding problems
and improving things
and making things better.
Now, I can achieve that leverage
through other people as well.
If I invest in someone and help them
and mentor them, it's just a way of,
in a sense, cloning myself.
And so, I actually enjoy
helping the next generation
of entrepreneurs.
It's something that's very meaningful
for me.
I love it. I love it.
So, Dan,
I'm warning you that in a few months
when I go on my own path
as an entrepreneur,
I will reach out
and seek for some advice
and for your help,
because I just can only imagine
the amount of knowledge
and experience you've accumulated.
And I personally
on a very similar journey
with all of my friends
that we're thinking of starting
some things together.
We're pretty much we have one big rule,
which is we want to make
a really big positive impact
and we want to feel satisfied
that we're doing something both
with the deep technology,
but at the same time really meaningful
to a big market such as health care,
and what you've done
both at Physera and with Khosla Ventures.
Before we leave,
thank you again for being on the show,
what are three words that you would use
to describe yourself?
So, I know you gave me a heads up,
Not enough of a heads up,
but I'm sorry for that.
So, it's ironic, but I wrote this down
at the beginning of the interview,
so I'm not making this up.
Wonderful.
I'll show you the notes.
It's like, it's curiosity.
You can see it.
Curious, helpful and efficient.
Curious, helpful, efficient.
Dan, toda raba.
Thank you very, very much.
And I'll see you at the next
J-Ventures meeting.
Looking forward to it.
Bye bye.